normalmente esta camarera aprovecha sus
descansos para revisar noticias en las
redes sociales pero en la antesala de
las elecciones las autoridades ugandesas
apagaron estas plataformas a las 130 no
me podía meter en nada en el apagón
llega después de que facebook cerrará
unas cuentas cercanas al gobierno el
lunes el gigante tecnológico afirma que
descubrió una red de perfiles falsos
vinculados al ministerio de información
una situación que ha tenido
consecuencias económicas directas en
gente como este vendedor de servicios
telefónicos
perdí muchos negocios porque tengo
clientes que viven muy lejos de aquí que
envían mensajes a través de las redes
sociales que hablan usando estas
plataformas y yo les respondo por ahí
también así que ahora mismo no nos
podemos comunicar sin redes en la vida
diaria se hace difícil en momentos de
crisis
communication esta es la única manera en
medio del cob y 19 a través de la que la
gente puede comunicarse con los centros
electorales y las líneas de ayuda es
aquí en donde pueden pedir ayuda si algo
está ocurriendo
con la votación en marcha estar al tanto
de lo que sucede podría ahora ser más
difícil para la mayoría de los ugandeses